>> Monica Valentine:
Good afternoon.
My name is Monica
Valentine and I work here
at the Library of Congress.
All day here at the Library of
Congress National Book Festival,
we are recognizing and
celebrating the importance
of reading and authors
and books.
The Library of Congress makes it
seem easy to do this every year,
but the truth is the
National Book Festival is a
huge undertaking.
It is a huge financial
undertaking.
And it is free for everyone
because of the generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
at LOC.gov/donate,
from the Festival app,
or when you purchase
books today.
Now onto the main event...
It is my pleasure to
introduce the author of one
of the most popular book
series in our Library
of Congress young readers'
center, "The Dork Diaries."
[ Cheering & Applause ]
We first met everyone's favorite
dork, Nikki Maxwell, in 2009.
Since then, Rachel Renee Russell
has published 12 Nikki Maxwell
tales, and the 13th, "Tales
of a Not-So-Happy Birthday,"
is due out on October 16th.
She sold over 30 million copies
of this New York Times
bestselling series
and the Max Crumbly series.
Be sure to visit the
book sales area today
where you can pick up her books.
Here to share more with
us about dork world,
we welcome Rachel Renee
Russell and Nikki Russell.
And Nikki Russell.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Good afternoon everyone,
I'm happy to be here!
Yay! We'd like to welcome you
to the National Book Festival,
and this is I think our fourth,
fourth or fifth time here.
And we love coming and you
know, seeing all you guys.
And it's a fantastic book
festival, one of our favorite.
So standing next to me is the
namesake for Dork Diaries,
her name is Nikki Maxwell.
This is my daughter,
Nikki Russell!
[ Applause ]
And not only was Nikki
and my older daughter Erin the
inspiration for Dork Diaries,
but Nikki illustrates it now.
[ Applause ]
So we're going to start off
by talking a little
bit about Dork Diaries.
We're going to do a dramatic
reading of my favorite chapter
in Dork Diaries Book 12,
and then at the end of that,
we're going to have a Q&A.
So if there's any
questions you'd
like to ask, we'll
take questions.
And then Nikki's going
to try to squeeze
in a couple of Dork-a-fications.
And the Dork-a-fications is
when she will actually draw a
few people out of the audience
as a Dork Diaries or
Max Crumbly character.
So we'll be doing that
at the very, very end.
So we have a lot to try to
get into our presentation.
So I'm going to have a seat.
And Nikki, you going to sit
down or you going to draw?
>> Draw.
>> Draw, okay.
Nikki's going to draw.
Okay, what you're seeing now
is the Dork Diaries series
at the bottom right is
Dork Diaries Book 1,
and then we've gone all the way
since 2009 to our newest book,
and that's Dork Diaries Book 12.
And this one came out
in October of 2017.
And our newest book will
be coming out October 2016
in just a few more months.
The brand new series that we
launched a couple years ago is
the Misadventures
of Max Crumbly.
And there's a video that...
>> Let's try that again.
This is Max Crumbly!
Super-powered eighth grader
at Southridge Middle School.
Alright, fine, Max
doesn't have super powers,
but if he could give
himself super powers
with weird glowing potions, the
first person he'd rescue is...
Himself. Because the truth
is, Max Crumbly's life stinks!
We're talking stinks
worse than Doug Thirsten.
And that's gas mask level stink.
In just two weeks,
Max has the record
for most tardy slips
in a single hour.
I earned the nickname "Barf"
after a rope climbing
mishap in PE.
And has been crammed into
his locker by Doug Thirsten
about 8 bajillion times.
The thing is, Max
could be a hero!
He'd go around saving the
world with his wicked raps.
>> What's up.
>> Rescue Erin Madison
in the school play
with his awesome art skills.
And maybe, just maybe, even
hone his serious bladder control
issues for good.
Yep, Max Crumbly
could be a hero!
But first, he'll need to survive
a three day weekend crammed
in his locker.
Find out what happens in "The
Misadventures of Max Crumbly,"
a new series by Rachel
Renee Russell,
author of the number
one best-selling series
"Dork Diaries," out now.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Thank you!
So just a little bit
about Max Crumbly.
Max is about to face the
scariest place he's ever been,
Southridge Middle School.
There's a lot that's great
about his new school,
but there's also
one big problem.
Doug Thirsten, also
known as Thug.
The school bully whose hobby is
stuffing Max inside his locker.
If only Max could be like the
hero of his favorite comics.
Read "The Misadventures of Max
Crumbly 1, Locker Hero" just
to see how much of
a hero Max can be.
So this was our first book
in the Max Crumbly series.
We also have written and
released a second one.
And that's "Max Crumbly book
2, Middle School Mayhem."
And we have a little
mini video for that one.
>> Nooo! Aaaahhh!
>> Nikki Russell: Alright, so my
job is to tell you a little bit
about "Max Crumbly book
2, Middle School Mayhem."
When we last left our hero, Max
Crumbly, he had crash landed
on top of a mighty
meat monster pizza
after taking a late-night
tumble through the bin
at Southridge Middle School.
And he was completely surrounded
by three ruthless criminals!
Will Max be shredded to
bits like mozzarella cheese
on the hard and crunchy
pizza crust of doom?
Or, can his friend and sidekick
computer whiz Erin help get him
out of this sticky
situation alive?
Find out in "The
Misadventures of Max Crumbly 2,
Middle School Mayhem."
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russell: And
our new book, which is coming
out on October 16th,
is "Dork Diaries,
Tales of a Not-So-Happy
Birthday!"
Nikki Maxwell is finally getting
ready to celebrate her birthday.
So again, this book will
be coming out October 16th
and you can preorder it.
Otherwise, you can buy it
on October 16th on
the release date.
And again, it will be released
on October 16th and we're back
with the normal cast
of characters.
We have Nikki, and of
course her two BFFs Zoe
and Chloe will be helping
her to plan the party.
Mackenzie will be there
trying to ruin her birthday.
And then of course we
have her crush Brandon,
and then there's wacky
Brianna, her little sister.
So we'll have the entire cast
back for "Dork Diaries Book 13,
Tales from a Not-So-Happy
Birthday."
[ Applause ]
Okay the next thing I'm
really excited about,
this is our first
time trying this,
we're going to do a short
reading from my favorite chapter
of "Dork Diaries Book 12."
It's this book here.
And it's the diary
entry of Nikki Maxwell
which is Sunday, May 25th.
And if you have the book and
you'd like to follow along,
it's going to start
at about page 67.
Nikki's going to be, I'm
going to be Nikki Maxwell
and I'll read her parts.
Nikki is going to do a
dramatic interpretation
of Brianna, Mom, and Dad.
So I'm going to set
things up a little bit.
Nikki and her family are
eating lunch together.
And Nikki's favorite television
show is a reality show called
"My Rich and Trashy Life."
And it's about these sisters
that are very, very wealthy
and they always have drama
going on in their lives.
And again, it's based off
of a real-life reality show.
But in "Dork Diaries,"
Nikki is really
into watching that reality show.
So as soon as she finishes
lunch, she wants to rush off
and watch her favorite
reality show,
but her mother has other plans.
Her mother has decided that it's
family game board afternoon.
So she wants the entire
family to sit down
and play a game board.
So we'll start with that.
>> Nikki Russell: Is everybody
ready for fun, fun, fun?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
I wanted to watch my
favorite reality show.
But no, mom wanted us to
have family game time.
Brianna came skipping
into the room
with a small bag behind her back
and an old pizza box covered
in finger paint and glitter.
>> Nikki Russell: Look at this!
I made my own game, and it's
called Brianna's Funnest
Game Ever!
You're going to love it!
Can we play it?
Can we, Mommy?
Please?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Briana pleaded.
>> Nikki Russell: We'd love
to play your game, sweetheart.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Mom smiled.
>> Nikki Russell:
It's going to be fun.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Briana opened her pizza box.
Inside was a handmade game
board with random squares
and colorful crayon scribbles
that made no sense whatsoever.
I couldn't tell which
direction to move
or where the finish line was.
It look like Brianna had
just chewed up some crayons
and spit them out on the
paper with her eyes closed.
>> Nikki Russell: Okay,
I'm going to be the boss.
Daddy, you can be the paperclip.
And mommy, you can be the penny.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: She
handed them their game pieces.
Cool, I get to be the cute
Barbie shoe, I smiled.
I picked up the tiny
pink sparkly high heel.
>> Nikki Russell: Nuh-uh.
That's mine.
Remember, it's my game.
I made it so I'm the boss of it.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Then
she stuck her tongue out at me.
I folded my arms
and glared at her.
Then what am I supposed
to use to play your game?
There's nothing left!
I grumbled.
Brianna checked inside
the box and sure enough,
there weren't any
more game pieces.
But she just shrugged
her shoulders at me
like it wasn't her problem.
That's when I got
a brilliant idea.
Oh no, Brianna, it looks like I
won't be able to play your game!
I'm so disappointed!
I pretend pouted, like
I was about the cry.
I guess I'll just have to
go and watch the finale
of "My Very Rich and Trashy
Life" while you guys have all
the fun.
But I'll get over it, bye!
>> Nikki Russell:
Hey, wait a minute!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Brianna grinned
as she peeled off a moldy piece
of pepperoni that was stuck
to the bottom of the pizza box.
>> Nikki Russell: Here Nikki,
this is your game piece!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Ewww!
I shrieked.
I don't want that nasty thing!
>> Nikki Russell: But
it's the best one!
If you get hungry and want
a snack, you can chew on it!
Then when it's your
turn to move again,
you just put the pepperoni
back on the game board.
I bet you can chew it
for just hours like gum!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
That's when I threw
up in my mouth a little.
Mom! I whined, waiting
for her to intervene.
>> Nikki Russell: Nikki,
you're spoiling the fun.
Brianna worked really hard
on this game, so simmer down!
Just take the pepperoni and
try to be a good sport, okay?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
I begrudgingly picked
up my nasty pepperoni, trying
to avoid the fuzzy mold
and dropped it on the start box.
It was misspelled "Stat."
>> Nikki Russell:
Mommy, you go first.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Mom rolled the die
and moved four spaced.
>> Nikki Russell: Now
this is the fun part.
You have to do whatever the card
I choose during the game says.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Brianna
squealed and pulled out a stack
of index cards written
in block marker
in her sloppy handwriting.
However, instead of taking a
card from the top of the stack,
Brianna quickly sorted
through them
until she found one she liked.
>> Nikki Russell: Here
Mommy, this is your card.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Mom read the card.
>> Nikki Russell: You are nice
and pretty like sugar plum.
Move forward seven spaces!
How sweet, this game is fun.
Okay, Daddy, your turn!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Dad rolled the die
and moved five spaces.
Then Brianna selected
a card for him.
Dad read.
>> Nikki Russell: Today is your
lucky day, do the hokey pokey
and then move ahead six spaces.
Woo-hoo!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Dad exclaimed.
He hopped to his feet and did
a rendition of the hokey pokey
that included the chicken
dance and some moves he stole
from a Justin Bieber video.
Ugh. Now I'll never be able
to watch that video again
without thinking of
Dad's hokey pokey!
Next it was my turn.
I tossed the die and
moved three spaces.
>> Nikki Russell: Uh-oh.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Brianna said,
reading the card she
had selected to me.
She handed it to me and
then read it out loud.
>> Nikki Russell: You
are ugly and eat boogers.
You lose a turn, sorry!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: What?
I shouted.
That's not fair!
Why do I have to be the
ugly, booger-eating loser?
>> Nikki Russell: Because it's
my game and I make the rules!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Brianna said all snotty-like
with her hand on her hip.
Okay, fine.
I grumped.
I thought this was
supposed to be fun.
I was so over Brianna's
stupid game.
>> Nikki Russell: Yay,
everybody, it's my turn!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Brianna giggled.
She rolled the die and moved
her Barbie shoe three spaces.
>> Nikki Russell:
Now I get a card.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: She
said as she quickly sorted
through the stack until
she found one she liked.
>> Nikki Russell: Oh goody,
my card says "You are the
bestest player and get
to have three pieces of candy
from the jackpot candy stash!
Congratulations!"
>> Rachel Renee Russell: What?
What do you mean, what
jackpot candy stash?
I exclaimed.
>> Nikki Russell: This one.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Brianna answered
as she grabbed the
plastic bag and opened it.
I almost had a heart attack.
Inside was my precious
candy stash.
That bratty little thief
has snuck into my room
and stolen my entire
stash of candy!
No way, I protested.
I hate this cruddy game.
Give me back my candy
stash, Brianna.
Give it back now.
>> Nikki Russell:
Aw, come on Nikki.
It's just candy.
You could always get more.
Let's just try to have
fun playing your little
sister's game.
I agree, this is an
opportunity for you
to be an excellent
role model for Brianna.
So try not to be a sore loser.
Listen to your father
and your mother.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
My mom admonished me.
There's no wonder I had
a really bad attitude
about the whole thing.
Every time it was my turn, I
ended up with a stupid card
that said something like.
>> Nikki Russell: You got
cooties without a cooties shot!
Go to jail!
Sorry!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Or.
>> Nikki Russell: You stink
really bad and need a bath!
Go back to start.
And then lose a turn.
Sorry!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: And
whenever it was Brianna's turn,
she got to eat several
more pieces of my candy.
I just sat there
glaring at the three
of them in complete disgust.
I couldn't believe I was being
forced by my very own parents
to watch my bratty little sister
eat my entire candy stash during
the finale of my
favorite reality show
"My Very Rich and Trashy Life!"
I was very tempted to
call the authorities
and report them for child abuse.
Finally Brianna had
an ingenious plan
to get her grubby little
hands on my property.
My candy stash.
But by the end of the game,
my sister had eaten
almost half of my candy.
She had chocolate all
over her face and hands
and was looking a little queasy.
>> Nikki Russell: My tummy.
Mommy I don't feel so-- so good.
Goodness, I think this game has
gotten completely out of hand.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: My mom
said, looking a bit flustered.
Dad scooped Brianna
up off of the floor.
>> Nikki Russell: You've had
way too many sweets, young lady.
I think you need to go get some
rest to cure that tummyache.
But I want to keep playing!
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
She whined in a weak voice.
>> Nikki Russell: I
never get to eat as much
of Nikki's candy as I want!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: A-ha!
Just as I had expected!
The whole point of
Brianna's stupid game was
to get into my candy stash.
And my mom and dad
had fallen for it.
I'll give Brianna points for
being a pig-tailed evil genius
and pink My Little
Pony sneakers.
But I refuse to feel
sorry for her.
The next time we have a
board game madness night,
we're going to play
a rigged game my way.
My board game is going to
be called "Brocolli-opoli"
and it'll feature all of the
foods that Brianna hates.
Watch your back, little sister.
You're going to get a
big, green, nasty payback
and it's going to be healthy.
I can't wait to give
Brianna a special card
from my game that's
going to say--
>> Nikki Russell: Today
is your lucky day.
You get to drink a
gallon of green smoothie?
Sorry? Ah, Nikki
I hate your game.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
And who knows?
If I'm feeling really
vengeful, I might just toss
in some moldy pepperoni
for extra flavor.
[ Applause ]
Okay, now we're going to
do a really quick Q&A.
So if you have a
question, you can line up,
I think there's microphones
back there.
Okay. We'll go back
and forth, okay?
>> What was your inspiration
for the Brandon crush?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
The inspiration
for Brandon crush was
actually my daughter Erin.
When she was in middle school
she had a tremendous crush
on a guy, but the entire year
she never said one single word
to him.
So the relationship between
Brandon and Nikki is kind
of a fantasy of if she was
able to talk to her crush,
what it may have been like.
So Brandon is inspired
by a real-life person.
>> What is your favorite Dork
Diaries book that you've wrote?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
My favorite Dork Diaries book
is always the newest one.
So right now it's this one.
"Dork Diaries book 12"
and more than likely,
once we release "Dork
Diaries book 13"
that will probably
be my favorite.
And I think it's because I
spend a year writing them.
And then you just
kind of get attached
to it since you're working.
And you can ask Nikki
a question, too.
>> How many more books do you
think you're going to write?
>> Rachel Renee Russell: I
will keep writing Dork Diaries
as long as you guys
keep reading them.
So. At this point, I
see no end in sight.
And we're working on
Dork Diaries book 14 now
and 13 will come out in October.
So I'll be at it for many
more years to come as long
as you guys keep reading.
>> How many books are
you planning on having?
>> Rachel Renee Russell: I'm
going to keep writing forever.
And ever and ever.
So yeah, at this point
there's no end in sight.
>> Where did you get the
inspiration for Brianna?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
For Brianna?
The inspiration for
Brianna was actually Nikki.
When Nikki was a little
kid, she was very active.
I'll put it that way.
And she was like taking
apart the television
and writing on the walls.
And she was very, very busy.
And she was very curious and
she had a wacky sense of humor.
So definitely Nikki is the
inspiration for Brianna.
>> Why did Nikki
have the crushes?
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Nikki
had crushes because a lot
of times, by the time
you get in middle school
and you start high school, you
start noticing guys and girls
in your classroom and
you start having crushes.
So we decided to give
Nikki Maxwell a crush
because that's kind
of what happens
when you're in middle school.
>> What's your inspiration
for each story you write?
>> Rachel Renee Russell: A
lot of each book has a theme.
Like for example "Dork Diaries
book 1" was Nikki entering an
art show.
And that actually
happened because Nikki
and Erin have both
entered art competitions.
The one with the
music was inspired
because when I was a little
girl, we had a girl band.
My sisters and I.
And we actually performed
at the Apollo Theatre.
So "Dork Diaries 3"
was based on that.
And so anyway, all of the
books are based on things
that have happened to either
myself or my daughters.
So they're kind of
based on real life.
So we'll just take
one more question.
>> What was your inspiration
for the first Dork Diary?
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
The inspiration
for the first Dork Diaries
was, I would say was inspired
by my two daughters,
Erin and Nikki.
And growing, they
were really tall
because their dad is like 6'4.
So they were really tall and
kids gave them a hard time
and teased them and bullied
them because they were so tall.
And a lot of times, like if
a parent came in to visit,
they would mistake Erin or Nikki
for a teacher's aide
or another adult.
And they were like
only 5th or 6th grade.
They just were really,
really tall for their age.
And since they got teased,
I thought if I ever
wrote a children's book,
I would try to talk about
bullying and dealing
with mean girls and
how to cope with them
and I would make it really
funny and inspire kids to hang
in there and deal
with the situations
in case they're experiencing
that same type of thing.
So I think we're all done now.
>> Nikki Russell: Alright, so
I have two pictures I was able
to do during this very short
sweet time we had together.
The first is a Dork-i-fication
of a young lady seated front
and center with the most
adorable red headband
on and bow.
Would you like to get up and
get your Dork-i-fication?
[ Applause ]
And the next artwork we
have, thank you Mommy.
The next artwork is
a Crumb-i-fication
of a gentleman here
to the far left
in a grey American flag t-shirt.
Come on up and get
your Crumb-i-fication!
Come on!
[ Applause ]
There you go.
I wish I could draw all of you!
But I'm afraid we ran
out of time for that.
So please give these
two a round of applause.
Thank you.
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
You can have a seat.
You can have a seat, dear.
>> Nikki Russell: Okay,
you can have a seat.
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Okay,
we're going to be signing books.
Is it, what time?
Is it 1 o'clock?
What time are we signing?
Anyway, we're going to be
signing books shortly after this
and we have lots of free stuff
because we love you guys!
So we have a Dork Diaries
book 12 gumball machine
and it has colorful gumballs
and a Dork Diaries sticker
and it matches our cover.
And we have stickers
and bookmarks
and Max Crumply Stickers and a
lot of lot of lot of fun stuff.
So we're looking forward
to seeing you guys
when you sign books.
Love you guys!
>> Nikki Russell: Hope to see
you soon at the book signing!
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Yep!
Always remember to let your
inner dork shine through
and be the hero you've
always admired!